hey guys today we're gonna talk about
green blood therapy now what is that
it's really just wheatgrass juice okay
but before I get started I want to just
differentiate a couple things there's a
lot of people consuming a lot of wheat
in the form of breads pastas certain
crackers biscuits waffles things like
that when you're consuming wheat you're
not consuming the wheat grass you're
consuming the wheat seed which is the
grain they take that grain they grind it
up and they put it into flour okay has a
lot of bad health effects when you
consume that especially in the refined
form okay but what I'm talking about is
the wheat grass juice juice powder type
products which basically is the baby
grass of the wheat plant okay which then
grows at a certain point and develops
seeds and that's where they take the
grain out but wheat grass doesn't have
any gluten especially in the early parts
where you would juice it but there's
some interesting studies mainly in
Europe in India and I'm gonna put some
links down below but there's one study
that is very very credible it was a
double-blind placebo-controlled study on
23 patients with ulcerative colitis and
what they found was significant
reduction in ulcers and in severity of
rectal bleeding okay and the reason they
saw that was there some property in
wheat grass that's really beneficial to
your skin not just external but internal
so a lot of people take it for ulcers
it's also good for bed sores irritable
bowel syndrome any type of inflammatory
condition internally related to the
digestive system and it does other
things too like for example there's a
study on a condition called beta
thalassemia which is a genetic condition
involving low hemoglobin the protein
that carries oxygen through the body and
because the chemistry of the chlorophyll
which is kind of like the blood of the
plant the green stuff is very similar to
our own blood with the difference of it
having magnesium instead of
I earn they found it's a good fortifier
for your blood in fact there are
benefits in over 50% of these patients
there was even a reduction of the need
for getting a transfusion which is quite
incredible
so chlorophyll is a blood builder it's
good for the skin but honestly you don't
really know exactly what in the
wheatgrass is doing this is it the
chlorophyll is it the vital nutrients
which there's a lot of is it the vitamin
E or the C or even the trace minerals we
don't know exactly but we do know that
wheatgrass has a lot of chlorophyll I
want to mention a couple things about
what chlorophyll can do as a side note
there's a toxin that comes from a fungus
called aflatoxin it's a very very
poisonous to your liver it can cause
liver cancer and it's higher in peanuts
corn soy other grains
well chlorophyll has the ability to
neutralize and reduce the effect of this
toxin so when someone consumes peanut
butter or peanuts it'd be a good idea to
also at the same time make sure you're
taking chlorophyll just to keep that
toxin at the lower levels and that can
be in the form of a salad a vegetable
wheatgrass juice powder or whatever and
it also neutralizes another toxic
element called alloxan which scientists
used to induce diabetes in mice in their
experiments you can also create a lock
sim if you combine the leached white
flour like when you buy flour at the
store like making bread pasta things
like that you have the unbleached in the
bleach that bleach combined with that
bread can increase your levels of the
locsin okay
well guess what chlorophyll can help
neutralize this too so that's really
cool so we differentiate what wheat is
versus wheatgrass okay and then you have
something called wheatgrass powder
that's really just concentrated
wheatgrass fiber there's probably not a
lot of chlorophyll or juice in there
because it's just all the fiber and then
you have wheatgrass juice okay from the
health of story you probably see that
all the time
that's a concentrated form of the the
juice from the wheatgrass okay so
extract this juice in a concentrated
form and then you have wheatgrass juice
powder okay now that's super
concentrated wheatgrass because if you
take the liquid and take the water out
it actually decreases majorly in volume
so I think it's like a five it's a two
to five percent yield but I really want
to differentiate the quality of this
wheatgrass juice powder if you're
getting the juice powder or even the
wheatgrass that's grown typically what
you see in the health of store on the
sponge not from a soil or from a sponge
and they juice it you're getting some
benefit but there's a huge difference in
if you're getting wheatgrass juice
powder grown on a very healthy soil over
a period of a month completely different
product because now we have the plants
ability to dig down and pull those trace
minerals and pull them up you're gonna
have higher chlorophyll levels you're
gonna have higher trace minerals
vitamins evel's and phytonutrients and
unfortunately a lot of the studies done
on wheatgrass do not involve the real
high level quality wheatgrass juice
powder and my thought is if you're
actually stepping it up and using a much
higher quality source you can even
probably get better results anyway
that's my opinion
don't stick into it thanks for watching
hey guys I'm not sure if you have my app
yet dr. Berg app it's totally free you
should download it okay this is what it
looks like you click it it gives you all
sorts of great resources I have all my
YouTube videos on this app okay and it's
regularly uploading the most recent ones
all the YouTube videos are also
converted to audio versions okay so you
can use it when you're walking
exercising driving your car I have a
mini course on there I'll be putting
additional courses I have a lot of
recipes on there this is new and also a
PDF resources so there's various
downloads PDFs that you can get as well
and if you wouldn't mind after you
download it check it out give me your
unbiased review and tell me how you like
it I want to know